-This is your first time
on a late-night talk show,
which is such an honor for us.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is weird!
-Yeah, this is all for you
You do have a little experience?
-I do.
This isn't my first rodeo.
-What was
your late-night experience
-In primary school, which is
when you're probably young
I don't know
the American version.
-Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
-You do, like, plays,
and one of the plays was,
where I was a talk-show host
and it was called
"The Rhianne Barreto Show.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
-That's a famous play.
-That's why
I'm wearing this suit.
I'm taking your job.
-You are!
Oh, my God.
I'm being usurped.
-But I would interview,
like, religious figures
to be like, "Why weren't you
the good Samaritan?"
-Oh!
-It was, like, very weird.
-Wow.
-It's like Dr. Phil, but like...
-Gotcha.
-Catholic.
-Was it well-received?
-Yeah.
I mean, I'm here.
Wait. You think you're her
because of that?
[ Laughter ]
-You were in the audience.
-We saw "The Rhianne Barreto
Show" years ago.
-Well, I had a banner made, an
then I put it on my bedroom wall
to, like,
assert power in my house.
-Gotcha. Because you --
And I should say,
power in your house,
you're 1 of 9?
-Yeah.
-1 of 9.
-I needed to be the favorite
[ Laughter ]
-And is it true,
everyone in your family,
all nine siblings
start with an R?
-Like the Kardashians.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Like the Kardashian
if there were more.
-But we pre -- we pre --
-You predated the Kardashians.
-That's the word.
I was thinking of preconceived
but that was not the right word.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, no,
my granddad started it,
and then we all followed suit.
-Gotcha.
And was there any fear
that you were gonna
run out of R names
along the line?
-I think we chose weird ones
-Okay.
-Like the Capitol of Italy
Rome.
-Rome, yes.
-Roma is one of them.
-Roma, uh-huh.
-Renata, like the custard tart
from Portugal.
-Okay.
-Rhianne was the most boring
-Really? 'Cause Rihanna's
pretty -- I would have said --
-You love her.
-I do.
-I'm budget Rihanna.
-You're budget -- [ Laughs ]
"Seth, Rihanna's
on the show tonight."
"Yes!"
It's like, "Rhianne..."
-Barreto.
And then I was like,
"From the talk show?"
And they were like, "Yes."
So very happy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is gonna be such
a weird segue
to this very serious movie
you're in.
Ready for this?
-I'm not.
-Okay, yeah.
-I got the giggles.
-But this is --
I mean, it's a wonderfully mad
film about --
This is a sexual assault
that happened to somebody
and that is captured
on cellphone,
and it's basically,
you are playing someone
who's trying to figure out
what happened
over the course of the night
-Yeah.
-And this is something that,
being from the U.K.,
you think happens less,
but there's less familiarity
with it there?
-I think more Americans exis
than British people,
just because you guys
have a big country.
-Yeah. Oh, you think,
it's just a numbers game.
-I was like,
"It's a numbers game."
But also, when I was --
You know, I'm pretty
Hermione Granger,
and I was like, "I need
to research and do homework,
bust she kind of, Pippa,
the wonderful writer-director,
restrained me from doing tha
and was like,
"I don't want you to researc
'cause the character
doesn't know what happened
So, you know, maybe you
shouldn't know what happened
so that when you're in a scene
with a lawyer,
and they're telling you
the reality of these crime
and how they go down,
you're really
actively listening."
And also,
the character doesn't remember
what happened that night,
so I never have to fabricate
memory of assault.
-And method is something -
You sort of get ostracized
in the film.
-Yeah.
-By your friends.
And I've read that you basically
did the same thing
with your cast mates --
you started being
friendly with them,
and then you kind of pulled away
as you got to those scenes
-Yeah.
-Is that something that you've
always sort of worked with
as a performer?
-I mean, yeah.
When I -- When I --
[ Light laughter ]
Sorry.
When I was younger,
I was in a showcase.
I went to the BRIT School --
Spider-Man went there.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah, it was good.
-Yeah, yeah.
-He came to my play once,
and was like one of the --
-Wow!
Wow.
-Spider-Man!
-Yeah.
-And then -- So, yeah.
So, that happened, and then
did a showcase to get an agent
And I was doing this play
called "The Wasps,"
and I had to like tie up
this woman and trap her,
and I was like,
"Ooh, acting is all about,
you know,
the most dramatic thing."
And so I tied my friend Naomi.
I was like,
"How about you try and escape,
and I just trap you
before I go on, so I feel it?"
-Oh, so this --
[ Laughter ]
So this wasn't --
Naomi wasn't on stage.
You were just
tying her up backstage?
[ Laughter ]
-So, I was like,
"Escape Trafalgar Studios,
and I will capture you."
And she's quite small, so I did.
-Well, that's smart.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, if you're gonna do that,
you pick
your smallest friend, yeah
[ Laughter ]
-She's massively talented,
and then I ran, captured her
tied her up,
put, like, tape on her face,
and then --
She consented, I swear.
[ Laughter ]
And then I like, went
to the wings and was like --
'Cause someone was performin
their monologue separate,
maybe a comedic one.
Who knows.
-Yeah, and they were
probably wondering
what's all that banging
backstage.
[ Laughter ]
-And then I was stroking
her hair in the wings,
and "Shh, shh."
[ Laughter ]
Tied up little girl.
And then the technician
could see what was happening
and he wrote a note saying
"Are you okay?"
[ Laughter ]
Held it up.
And my friend had to be like..
[ Laughter ]
It was so -- so...
Yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
They say...
-What do they say?
-They say if you ever see
an abduction taking place,
you want to hold up a note
[ Laughter ]
You definitely want
to hold up a note
just to make sure
everything's okay.
-Yeah.
-You won an award,
and you actually shouted out
the podcast host
of your favorite podcast.
-God, yeah.
-Yeah.
-I've done every interview
and shouted them out,
and they haven't responded
-Your favorite podcast is...
-"My Favorite Murder."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes.
-Any Murderinos in the house
-And so, you were
calling them out by name.
-Yeah, and my family --
So, I was like, "Thank you, Mom,
thank you, Dad," da da da da da,
and then I went,
"Thank you, Karen and Georgia,
who i love, and who the director
told me to listen to
in preparation for the film,
accent-wise.
And so my family responded
like, "Who are these women
that you
want to thank after us?"
And, yeah,
I just absolutely love them.
-And you still haven't gotte
anything back from them?
-They don't like me.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
-I think they're gonna see thi
and realize
you're the same girl
from the talk show.
-Yeah!
-And --
-They definitely saw that, too
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It was so great meeting you
and having you here.
-Thank you.
-What a delight.
Thank you so much.
Give it up for
Rhianne Barreto, everybody